that's refreshing very healthy okay i
was completely wrong it is the king's
pawn opening and uh magnus now bringing
his bishop out very early so this uh
avoids what we call the petrov defense
that was jan de ponyochi's
opening of choice in the world
championship match and now white's
bishop having come out
allows this pawn to push forward without
blocking a bishop in white's opening
what will jan do he brings his bishop
out
and uh very sensible stuff by both sides
so far specialty of people living in a
county called sussex really yes uh the
county where david's from popular
everyone plays it with white and black
meanwhile white's knights coming out
here in this game um he's i started
working with him when i was six years
old it lasted for three or four years
the collaboration and the openings he
taught me he would basically teach them
to everyone else and
i guess because i was relatively
successful with those openings everyone
started playing them everyone took them
up and
okay meanwhile a few moves white's
knight going to the edge of the board
it's going to trade itself off for
blacks dark squared bishop so not the
typical italian game that we would
we would usually see
instead white just going for a small
strategic advantage of the bishop pair
taking as much space as possible on the
edge of the board and i have to say it
is a rare move out of all the ones is
probably around about number eight a
choice in my database the pawn pushing
forward just fixing the black doubled
pawns on the b-file
where they are and okay some mysterious
bishop moves from both sides and yeah
still a lot of tension there we go
black's the first to castle
white does the same
and
despite the fact this is relatively
balanced relatively level position still
as usual between these two far from a
draw as
since you only played chess for a few
years now katrina what sort of tip um
has been the most helpful for you well
that's a formula you like as well right
you like especially the puzzles i love
the puzzles yeah and uh
okay yeah now i remember what they said
they write and uh
it's been very very handy wow okay i
mean well some moves on the board white
now just pushing a pawn up controlling
some squares we saw a similar theme in
the first game katrina mentioned this
white pawn push on the h file just
covering some squares stopping any pins
just marking out their territory just
putting their pawns on decent squares
and okay magnus going for a pawn
sacrifice this pawn push happened just
one move ago or no i mean a few moves
ago and now he's pushed it one square
further and the pulmonary has uh well
you know he's kind of thrown through and
throwing down the gauntlet in a
different way he's kind of said well
let's explode open the center
yeah and really combative really
challenging uh idea there from yana
pognashi i have introduced and katrina
from
obviously streaming and uh and playing
at the same time this pawn push by yana
pognechi after magnus had run away from
the bishop trade which i mentioned would
suit black yan has pushed in the center
he's really trying to just clarify
everything simplify everything trade off
all the pawns
the downside for black is that opening
the position might favor white's bishops
long term but if black is able to
eliminate the white bishops uh before
the position becomes too open then i
think black should be fine
i must admit i'm surprised the
evaluation bars so far in white's favor
because
okay it's not a huge advantage but to me
on the board it looks like jan is just
doing everything right to neutralize
magnus's uh first move advantage to the
advantage of the white pieces
now we see more trades and yan just
looking off to the side he's comparing
maybe two or three moves he can take
back this pawn that has just moved for
white with his own pawn with the black
pawn or he can capture white star square
bishop with the black knight you know
even though the knight isn't a really
good square
and he does it the bishop might have
long term potential and yep you're right
he does it that's a beautiful light
square bishop that uh black has is
sitting in the middle of the board but
uh right now white has to take this
piece back two options take with the
knight which is very safe okay he does
actually do this the reason i was maybe
expecting the queen to take is because
yes bishop takes knight will shatter the
white pawn structure but once the
queen's come off we will see that uh
maybe this pawn stretcher can be
defended meanwhile white having a very
strong bishop here stopping blacks rook
from coming out and now jan
seizing the ball by the horns not just
playing the safe move pawn takes pawn
we've seen this time and time again from
him in this final playing brave chess
playing courageous chess jumping in with
his knight and going for the white king
and uh she was also playing not in the
russian women's super final she was
playing in the mail the open cp yeah big
things and so just to go to the board
because we saw magnus actually played
the last resort move that we didn't
expect yeah i think magnus maybe just
one eye on the clock realizing he's
really low on time already
he decided okay safety first chess
dropping the white bishop all the way
back
uh back to act as a defender and as
mentioned black just regained his pawn
he recaptured a pawn that he had given
earlier and jan he's leaning back
he's got to be very content with what
he's been doing meanwhile white's night
going in this direction very surprising
it's very surprising but i see magnus's
plan because at the end of it
i'm uh black is not going to be better
yeah maybe we can show this because uh
the reason we're surprised is the knight
is going off towards the queen side when
actually maybe it is needed later to
defend its king and uh okay black brings
the queen out that's very sensible we'll
look at this in a moment but after
knight takes pawn your bankers move
winning a pawn temporarily at least just
deflecting away this bishop as mentioned
from the defense of its knight
suddenly is a pawn up but after for
example a queen trade uh i'm not sure
which black black rook captures here
then this pawn drops at the end and
suddenly alice the a pawn is going to
match up the board
very quickly and also promotes on a
light square so the reasoning behind
that night move has been uh has been
shown he attacked the black bishop the
black bishop retreating and now he is
using this knight as a defender and
harassing the black queen at the same
time actually finding a really nice
maneuver to hold the
balance and there we go the queen lights
herself up with the white king
very sensible
and uh if black gets the time black
would love to push one of the two pawns
forward either harry the h pawn or
freddie the f born to kick away that
white knight from its square they drew
the first game and if we do have a
winner in today's
rapid match then that player will be the
winner uh meanwhile this last move by
by magnus sorry caused jan to frown
yan's still frowning again
i mentioned in the last game magnus's
instincts his spidey senses told him
that there was something in the position
now yan's uh instincts are telling him
the same and while jan has just given up
a piece sacrificed tonight now the black
rook attacking the white queen but if
the white queen moves white is simply
lost black has actually got a
checkmating attack white has to just
capture this black knight bite the
bullet
and uh
it's actually a counter attack against
the black queen so white can play pawn
takes knight attacking the black queen
and white will be a piece up the
evaluation bar thinks
napoleon's just blundered i think this
is just a big risk uh that he's taking
right now he has seen this and he thinks
he's getting to the white king and then
we saw white capturing attacking the
black queen no time for black to capture
the white queen black would have just
been a piece down there but there will
be some tricks along the way and jan
very surprisingly uses this rook to hit
the white queen
and uh okay there must be a reason he
left this rook on a square it's blocked
white's queen now hit and it shuffles
out of the way
i'm very very very surprised by that
move actually you know and the queen as
dave is highlighted can swing across
when she wants to
yeah and uh jan
has pushed harry uh this h-born marching
forward
and okay this must have been his idea
but this is met by magnus just
retreating his knight a really ugly
passive square but it looks fine for now
the only safe square actually because
now a check
from the white king uh from the black
queen to the white king is just blocked
by the white queen if the queens come
off this knight will activate later and
decide the game white is simply a knight
for a only a pawn up there's no follow
through
uh so okay right now he has been
thinking for a long time jan but it's
too late and okay he lifts his rook up
the board so as mentioned trying to
swing that rook across to check the
white king from the front but this rook
can just be traded off
and
after this exchange black hitting the
rook in the corner the white rook
uh
in the eye line of the black queen but
that attack has been blocked is that
is that a big risk for him in this
situation or is it quite easy for him
now well it's never going to be easy for
him because his king is in danger and
until that situation is resolved then he
can sit back and enjoy the extra piece
until then it's just defense consolidate
repair work all the way and this
position
it looks like he should be able to get
there but with three minutes on the
clock your king's slightly airy
yeah it's definitely not a given a
similar case today i doubt we'll see the
same mistake twice from the world
champion and okay now offering to trade
off the bishops very sensible trying to
get rid of one of black's best attacking
pieces that black bishop has been
cutting the board in half controlling
some key squares black now creating a
pin
hitting that white bishop with the queen
and with the bishop himself
but this can be blocked you're probably
used to that katrina yeah screaming
you're used to speaking out loud even if
it goes good or bad definitely and i
know that people are watching all the
time so i have to be careful sometimes
on what i say
neighbors knocked on the on the door one
morning in my flat okay magnus just
trying to trade rooks now getting to
safety the tv
plates have gone
yeah yeah
right yeah i mean that's that's the
person that you take it out
not plates
not uh computers and uh let's just catch
up with the current game bishops came
off the board rooks came off the board
black actually won another pawn in the
process so now a quick count shows that
white has an extra knight but black has
two pawns in return so some compensation
at least but the problem is black's
pawns are far far away from pushing or
promoting they are not dangerous at all
so white tonight at some point will
start to coordinate with its queen and
the white queen and knight together
should overwhelm black's forces feels
like a distant dream right now for the
pontiac to ever get that type of
perpetual check that will save him so
white meanwhile centralizing his queen
this is what magnus loves to do
and he's got all the time in the world
to start improving the white knight
there we go the white king's super safe
tucked away in the corner
and this is why also having a queen in
the middle of the board is so good it
stops potential checks from the enemy
queen
and yan meanwhile at least hitting a
pawn he's trying to make it as difficult
as possible he's fighting
credit to him it's actually the creation
of a past pawn say for instance you just
push your pawn the b7 move it up two
squares and then you know instead of
capturing back you try to run with your
own pawn but unfortunately
now magnus has put his knight in the
center that's never ever gonna happen so
okay well
he tries the more pawns that do
disappear the closer black gets to a
draw if the queens come off at some
point if white only has one pawn
remaining maybe you have some chances of
eliminating the remaining white pawn uh
so if white's two pawns disappear then a
queen trade would actually save black
the problem is now after this uh kind of
transition that you mentioned ivanka of
the pawns being traded white's knight
and queen are combining and they are the
most fearsome attacking combo
and uh look
okay this is a check but once white's
king retreats or wow steps up the board
super brave by magnus the white knight
is threatening some deadly checks
already look how centralized the white
queen and knight are this is
a really instructive technique from
magnus carlsen centralized pieces
especially queens and knights
often cause
a hell of a lot of damage so white's
king joining the fun uh it's gonna close
the mating net around the black king and
that's why jan
moves his queen down one square he's
stopping the white king from continuing
to advance what more would you make if
you were whitey or katrina i think i
would push the pawn and then i would get
my king out to age six right walking the
king because i just had a mate like that
uh where i walked my king up and i don't
think that the opponent thought about it
but then i brought my queen up to the g7
square right in front of the king
and then it was made yeah let's just
show that pattern because pattern
recognition is so important in chess and
it's coincidental that it happens the
night yeah yeah you see this uh by
magnus carlsen but let's keep an eye on
the players as well black's queen came
across because if black had been
careless just to show this pattern the
white king is actually going to act as
the attacker and the white king stepping
in is going to deliver this checkmate
and this would just be game over and uh
okay let's go back to the players
because jan has stopped this idea with
the black queen oh and 100 on the bar
yeah we're about to see checkmate let's
go back to the players can we get their
faces on the camera
white queen is just going to step across
one square it's checkmate next move the
black king is going to move the white
knight will deliver the killing blow
there we go the first win of the final
wow and of course it happens in game six
magnus cross and he wins this game with
the white pieces he goes up by one point
in the final and that means gianna
pognachi he has now two games he has to
win one of them to take this to tie
breaks